um I'm
I apologize a local TV journalist was
overcome with emotion covering the
murder of one of their own Wednesday
night outside Orlando Spectrum News 13
says 24 year old Dylan Lyons was killed
the Spectrum 13 reporter was engaged to
be married
the deadly Rampage began near a crime
scene where a woman was found shot in
her car earlier in the day in the Pine
Hills neighborhood police say for
unknown reasons the suspect returned to
the scene deputies located two men who
had been shot in or near a vehicle they
are News 13 reporter and photographer
who were on the scene to cover the
homicide from this warning the gunman
then allegedly went into a nearby home
and shot a mother and her nine-year-old
daughter killing the child